ابدا من حيث انتهيت من عمليه ان قط جنوب
القطاع سياخذ وقتا مع الجيش الاسرائيلي
اشهر يقول اشهر لان احد ال القاده
الميدانيين قال ان لا خبره لديهم بعد في
الطبيعه الجغرافيه لجنوب القطاع اذا نبدا
من المنطقه الجنوبيه من خان يونس تحديدا
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقول بان الموضوع ان
القتال في المنطقه الجنوبيه يسير ببطء
وقال ان هذا البطء يعود لتعدد المحاور
التي يقاتل فيها في خانيونس هناك قتال في
الجراره عاد القتال مجددا وهي الى الشمال
من من مدينه خان يونس بني سهيلا تبقى
منطقه اشتباك قويه وايضا خزاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعتقد ان هذه المنطقه المحاذيه
للشريط الحدودي لا سما بني نسيله وخزاعه
يقول بانها قد تكون من المقرات الاساسيه
لحركه لكتائب القسام ولذلك يكثف من عمليات
قصفه واستهدافه ولكن اليوم هناك محاولات
ايضا للدفع بقوات مؤله الى هذه المنطقه في
خزاعه بدات من يوم امس وهناك عمليات تفجير
لمبان واستخدام الجرافات لازاله الركام من
منطقه خزاعه كي لا تستخدمها المقاومه كاف
خاخ وهي التي برعت في استهداف الجيش
الاسرائيلي بهذه الافخاخ خان يونس لا يزال
القتال فيها مستمرا وان تعددت اليوم
وتوسعت العمليات في خانيونس هناك من معن
عادت الاشتباكات وايضا من
النواحي الشرقيه والشماليه وسط مدينه
خانيونس ايضا هناك قتال ضار وهناك استهداف
من قبل كتائب المقاومه الجديد اليوم ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي تحدث عن عمليه له جرت
الى الغرب من مدينه خانيونس في محافظه
خانيونس الى الغرب قرب البحر يقول انه
اغار على واحده من المباني وان قوه راجله
دخلت الى احد المباني لتجد
هناك شبه غرفه عمليات مصغره وعتاد لكتائب
القسام طبعا الاعلان اتى على موقع الجيش
الاسرائيلي و وليس على لسان المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي المنطقه الوسطى هي منطقه
اشتباكات قاسيه اليوم اضيفت اليها جبهه
جديده وهي الزوايده كان الجيش الاسرائيلي
على مدى الايام القليله الماضيه يهاجم
منطقه البريج والنصيرات والمغازي بشكل
كثيف يحاصر هذه المناطق من ثلاث جهات من
الشمال ومن الشرق ومن الجنوب كان هناك
الهجوم على المغازي ولكن الذي حدث اليوم
ان الزوايده اشتعلت وهناك هجوم كثيف من
قبل قوات الاحتلال على منطقه الزوايده
ومقاومه ضاريه يقول الجيش الاسرائيلي لا
نعرف من
اين ياتي ال الفلسطينيون لمهاجمتها
ويقصدون بفصائل المقاومه الزوايده هامه
جدا لاسباب عده اولا لان اذا تمت السيطره
سيطر قوات الاحتلال على الزوايده سيمكنها
ذلك من الدخول من ناحيه الغرب الى البريج
والى المغازي والسيطره عليهما بشكل كامل
اضافه الى تعزيز قطع شارع صلاح الدين
الرئيسي وبالتالي احداث الفصل الكامل بين
المناطق الشماليه في المحافظه الوسطى
والمناطق الجنوبيه ايضا نتحدث عن المنطقه
الوسطى وتبقى هناك ايضا اشتباكات متفرقه
بحسب ما افاد مراسل جزيره مؤمن الشواف قال
ان هناك ايضا اشتباكات متفرقه في منطقه
جحر الديك القريبه جدا على الشريط الحدودي
الشمال لم يعد هادئا كما كانت اسرائيل
تقول كانت اعلنت انها اتمت العمليات
العسكريه في شمال القطاع لكن اليوم اشتعلت
نقاط في الشمال لا سما مخيم جباليا ومدينه
ماليا الى الغرب منهما هناك اشتباكات قويه
ويبدو ان هناك محاوله اسرائيليه للدخول
الى منط الى هاتين المنطقتين مره اخرى
طبعا هذا كله يجري بينما يقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه يحاول ان يحسن من اداء
قواته ولكن تحسين اداء هذه القوات
بات يتم ربما عبر كثافه استخدام ال
المساعدات على العمليه العسكريه تم رصد
طائرات مسيره تحلق في مناطق واسعه من قطاع
غزه اضافه الى استمرار تحليق الطائرات
المقاتله وبات الجيش الاسرائيلي هذا نهج
بدا يستخدمه منذ قرابه اسبوع بشكل مكثف
بات يستخدم الطائرات المسيره لاستهداف بعض
المناطق وايضا للاستهداف الفرديه بمعنى
انه يستخدم طائرات استطلاع مسيره مثل تلك
التي اسقطها كتائب القسام في هذه المنطقه
واسمها سكايلارك لكن هناك طراز اخر من
الطائرات المسيره المقاتله تسمى الطائرات
الهجوميه وايضا اسقطت كتائب القسام في
عمليه مشتركه مع سرايا القدس واحده منها
وتسمى هيرمس 900 وهي من صناعه اسرائيليه